one of the things that's happening in
Bangladesh is that you see a huge
migration of people are moving from the
countryside's words the capital so I was
traveling around Bangladesh looking for
images of people on the move when I
found this picture of two young men
sleeping on top of the train room I was
intrigued because when I clambered up on
the roof I had figured that people would
be sort of hunched together holding on
to railings or whatever to make sure
then slide off the slippery roof so sort
of amazed to see two guys happily is
really asleep you know for hours on end
not holding onto anything I'm filled
with admiration for Bangladeshis in the
sort of calm manner they deal with so
many challenges it speaks to the
incredible quality they have to this or
get on with life